you want to build max strength engaging
the fast twitch muscle fibers and larger
motor units during your training is
essential problem is the body won't
engage these muscle fibers unless the
demand placed on it requires them we use
the weakest and smallest motor units
first before adding bigger ones as
required that's fine if you have a
really heavy weight to use but if you're
training from home or don't like
training heavy it's more of an issue
there are still a few options one is to
train to failure or close to failure and
you'll know that you're engaging the
large motor units because you'll notice
yourself starting to to shake as smaller
units start to become fatigued your body
has no choice but to call upon the
larger motor units that are still
available because the smaller motor
units add smaller amounts of additional
Force to the movement think of it as a
plus one or a plus two but the bigger
motor units add A+ 10 or a plus 20 and
you can't use part of a larger motor
unit that means that as they start
firing up you'll see a bigger step
change in the amount of force being
applied the movement therefore becomes
jerky and less
precise